Well hello again everybody. This is Session 4 of a new look at cancer last week. We talked about
ucogenes and
What turns those ucogenes on so that's really what we talk about causes so what caused the person's cancer so
was it a virus or was it a heavy mental toxicity or was it a chemical toxicity that they're exposed to as a child or
We're really talking about what causes and we're talking about
From multi-different levels the cause can can increase
Expression of an ucogen it can decrease
Expression of a suppressor gene it can directly affect the receptor site
in a specific
Receptor typically an apoptonic receptor it can affect inside the cell
so like a cancer virus typically affects inside the cell and
causes a
breakage in the
interbutation and the
replication cycles so we talk about chemicals or virus or bacteria or radiation and things like that
That's what we're talking about. Is it affecting the ucogen
Expression increasing it is it decreasing the suppressor gene is it directly affecting the cell somehow
so from it from a
Straight hereditary standpoint of cancer. It's almost a butoid to talk about so we're not even to talk about there are
certain hereditary cancers. There's
But even it let's say retinoblastoma which is a
childhood cancer of the high
the percentage of
children with retinoblastoma
That do not have any
Express gene for retinoblastoma. There's actually a retinoblastoma gene is is half of the population of retinoblastoma patients so
There's very few hereditary cancers. So even you talk about a suppression of the BRCA 1 and BRCA 2
That is the breast cancer where Angelina Jolie had that genetic mutation. So she had her breast removed
You're going to find that to be that is a ridiculous thing to do there's ways that you could that you could
turn off the
Expression of those oncogenes as you will see that as we go here
so
Top six causes of cancer admitted women. This is listed solely by
Cancer research in the UK and it is solely based upon what is
Straight forward knowledge tobacco. Obviously rakes the highest across the board in the biggest common cause of
Tobacco what what tobacco causes is typically smell cell a
Cancer in the lung
So and that is the lead cause of death at all cancers. So
For whatever reason there's still
Is Betty smokers and is Betty's new smokers as there ever was before
But lack of food in vegetables is what they listed for men interested occupational hazards bestus
Bestus other chemical hazards alcohol overweight exposure to sudden sunbeds
I take argument with that, but
There's so many chemicals in tobacco and I'm we hardly ever talk about tobacco partly because my mind isn't even there
I'd never smoked before and you just don't see smokers anymore
So if you're a non-smoker and you don't have
Friends or loved ones that are smokers. It kind of falls off your radar
Unfortunately, there's just as many smokers today if you look at the statistics as there as there has been at least the statistics
And I saw which is kind of mind-boggling given all the knowledge and how dangerous
Smoking is
Believe it or not. I've had cancer patients small cell cancer patients that still refuse to stop smoking
Certainly have a number of patients. It's still smoke. It's a it's so there the chemicals in the cigarette are so addictive
That's how that's how they keep you smoking so there's addictive substance is effect the brain and it's a huge
very difficult
Addiction to overcome
H by Laura helical vector by Laura a very very common cause of cancer
It's the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide. By the way
H. Pylora will do a whole presentation on that but H. Pylora is a gram-degative bacteria. So
It is ubiquitous. That means it's everywhere. You will you will be exposed to you have already been exposed to H. Pylora
How H. Pylora in faxas is food board so you ingest it?
You could get it through kissing someone you could get it through
Head a food handler having H. Pylora. It is everywhere you were exposed to it
Maybe maybe at a weekly basis, maybe at a monthly basis
Now why don't you why does it everybody have a H. Pylora infection? Well
Sad to save that probably 50% of the world's population have an undiagnosed H. Pylora infection
I'm not going to get into that right now, but normally H. Pylora should be killed by your stomach acid
So would you have adequate H. C. L. production by your
Prital cells of your stomach and
You had that will give you a low pH
Various acidic environment in your stomach. So when food board pathogens like H. Pylora
I enter into the stomach cavity that H. C. L. kills them and you never get any of the effects of H. Pylora
So H. C. L. not only digests your food breaks it down into smaller particles
But it is your first light of defense against food board pathogens and H. Pylora is a biggie
so
H. Pylora if you google it you'll find your majority of your articles are going to be on
stomach ulcers because H. Pylora is the cause of stomach ulcers
But it's the cause of many cancers. It's the cause of
endothelial
dysfunction. It's one of the top five causes of heart disease
So there's a lot to be talked to be said about H. Pylora and I love to talk about H. Pylora
So we'll have many presentations on that
There's other causes of cancer other exposures vaccine exposures
Nobody wants to talk about that, but it's true old vaccines are a major cause of cancer the chemicals in those vaccines are
Injected into your bloodstream at a concentration that almost always exceeds your liver's ability to detoxify them
So you are going to be poisoned by them
Fluoride here's a quote by Dr. D. Burke. He says
In point to fact fluoride causes more human cancer death it causes it faster than any other chemical
Look at our presentation
For a present look at our on the by hope online for a presentation on fluoride if you don't see it
It'll be coming out soon. It's already been created. It'll scare your socks off
So you've heard you are what you eat we're exposed to all these chemicals
We eat these foods with additives, colorings, flavorings, all these bad fats these trans fats and oh
We can't barbecue with the with the meat and cook it too hard at all these different chemicals that we're exposed to in our foods
That are cytotoxins and chemicals all these are bad things
Is it true you are what you eat?
Well, you know, I guess in a sense you are but really you are what you absorb so not just what you eat
You know, you have to absorb it and you absorb things through your skin too
So not only are you getting chemicals through your food?
You're getting chemicals through your shampoo through your soap through you all the lotions that you put out your skin
The foundation and the eye shadow and the lipstick you women are wearing all the creams in the sun blocks
That's a horrible one all those chemicals are going into your bloodstream
Hey, and you're absorbing through your lungs. That's actually the fastest way to get something in unless you're injected into your bloodstream
Like a vaccination or some drug you are absorbing through your lungs
You breathe it in your alveolar spaces crosses right into your bloodstream
It is circulating your blood with it a matter of seconds
One of those chemicals where you go to the gas station the chemicals gas it off your carpeting
Gas it off new construction flooring. I it just is endless. It is just
Absolutely endless. It's just don't write scary. Are you what you eat? Yes? Are you what you absorb?
Well, that's even better. Really you are what you don't detoxify
So all those chemicals go into our body and are circulating in our blood and
Your body has two choices number one. It's going to try to detoxify them
So they go through those liver detox pathways
Remember we talked about last week about the methylation pathway. That's one of them
So if you have a defective that methylation pathway from other epigenetic changes
Then you are even going to be a slower detoxifier. So even if you have a
100% function of all your detox pathways you could overwhelm them
Overwhelmed them because you are toxifying yourself at a greater rate that your liver is able to detoxify you
So a rule of thumb is this if you are
Toxifying yourself at a rate greater than your ability to detoxify you are poisoned
So now what is your body going to do you this
Toxin is circulating through your bloodstream and you are going to die of toxicia
Unless you do this wonderful other thing that God put in your body. You should these toxins to fat cells
So we're not talking about just fat at your belly
Manifact we're talking the least about fast at your belly. We're talking about your more
Vascular fat. That is the fat around your organs
Why could you go play football and get hit and your thyroid doesn't pop out of your body because you have a nice round fat layer
Holding your thyroid together and keep it in a place same thing with all your organs
You have this nice beautiful fat layer
Cushiony the below so you can walk and run and play
Hop scotch and your liver doesn't you know fall down to your
Pelvis because it's held together with with tissue that is mainly made of fat
Well, your fat cells think of your fat cells as heavy
Well, let's say the gift of
Accommodation so they are constantly inviting toxins in and that's where toxins can get stored
So greater exposure to toxins greater than your ability to detox circulate through your blood get shut to defat cells and there they're held
Hopefully, hopefully ever after but it's court fortunately it can cause all sorts of problems
So we'll talk about those that we go next week. What do we do about it?
And we're just going to keep digging it into this all right Dr. Cutters hope this is good for you